I want to make a very special
announcement here I'm excited to say
that
um I have the crab Feast podcast back
under my control okay so uh it's every
artist's goal to get their you know
property back to them we got it all
right so
um
if you don't know about the crab Feast
um but a lot of you do I want to say
this I'm on the road meet and greets
people come up been rocking with you
since the feast man the feast the feast
the crab Feast is a podcast that I did
with Jay Larson it's a storytelling
podcast Audio Only
um we did it for about seven and a half
years there's 350 some episodes hell if
you if you listen to two a week it would
take you three and a half years to get
through it but it's a phenomenal library
that I'm very proud of
um it's what
um proceeded the Honeydew for me
um and it's got all the same favorite
guests you love sagora Bert Kreischer
Bill Burr Christina p uh you name it
there's and they're all different
stories too so if you love the Honeydew
you gotta check out the crab Feast
um subscribe to it today it's still
getting a ton of downloads already
there's an active community on Facebook
that goes through every episode uh and
it's been almost gone for four years
years now so
um feasters let them know uh honeydew
fans if you are looking for you're all
caught up on a honeydew and you're like
what else can I listen to I'm telling
you go listen to The Crab Feast it is a
fantastic fun uh storytelling podcast
you know there you'll get like man I got
this weird ghost story in a near death
and a marriage story into this where
that's what you know I the Honeydew for
me was the crab fees needed to have a
baby and I just focus on highlighting
the low lights here so go check it out
it's available everywhere you get
Podcast it's audio only like I said
subscribe
um join the fan pages have fun with it
I'm going to be promoting it every week
here on the Honeydew now that it's uh
back in in control here so I'm very
excited about that thank you feasters
thank you honeydew fans enjoy the feast
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I am Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media if you are watching this
show first of all thank you second of
all please hit that subscribe button
alright I say it all the time it's a
free way to help the show cost you
nothing means zero to you and everything
to us all right and if you gotta have
more then you gotta check out the
patreon all right it's staying at five
bucks a month next year so I'm just not
moving it all right and if you sign up
for your year you get a month free and
I'm highlighting the low lights with you
all and I promise you we're gonna do
another highlight episode just so you
can get a sample of the kind of [ __ ] I
see every [ __ ] week from y'all
phenomenal if you or someone you know
has a story that has to be heard please
submit it to honeydewpodcast gmail.com
hopefully we get to do an episode
together all right and I want to just
keep reminding you all about the crab
feast all right it is back under our
control
um it is a Audio Only podcast and I
promise you if you're looking for a new
podcast go check out this old podcast
it's all the same people you know Harlan
Williams was on there Tom segor Burke
Chrysler Bill Burr Christina pachitzki
all the people you know and love right
there with different [ __ ] stories
that's the truth go subscribe it's
available everywhere you get your
podcast uh and also specifically La I
want to say thank thank you all so much
for coming out to the special we had a
blast I can't wait to show it all to you
I'm very excited about that now that's
the biz you all know what we're doing
over here highlighting those low lights
these are the stories behind the
storytellers and I'm very excited to
have this gentleman back here on the
Honeydew ladies and Gentlemen please
welcome back Harley Williams welcome
back to the Honeydew heart oh dude just
like startled me there welcome back yeah
a little jump can we just tell everybody
real quick it's the holidays right now
and we were outside yeah Kirsten and I
are out there with the dog we're smoking
a joint talking to you and there's a
Christmas tree
[Laughter]
right next to us yeah all kinds of
beautiful uh Christmas movies yeah
beautiful
um nordman's and Douglas Firs and all
these Nobles that's what we got also we
got a noble Balsam yeah so uh this nice
older lady says excuse me do you work
here in Harlan [ __ ] says no I got
fired
for molesting a lot of the trees and
this woman took that [ __ ] right stride
she loved it
she goes you looked at that he said I
licked the hell out of him
that sap can't not like it and then she
comes back she's like they're getting a
whole new load at nude she loved it she
loved it dude you're hilarious yeah
we're good energy Harlan Williams yeah
well you know if someone in the public
wants to improv with me I'll improv all
day right why not all day that's the
best and it's rare that people just will
jump in and improve with you the [ __ ]
out of you dude it's fun it is yeah yeah
um well before we get into your stories
today please uh plug everything you like
well hey man I will uh just mention my
podcast the Harlan highway on YouTube
and uh it's a show where we just talk
about everything and anything we Meander
down the highway and we go off all the
different exit ramps and just have fun
and uh great guests like yourself and
that was fun dude uh everyone's been on
it and uh so chat check it out the
Harlan Highway podcast
um also check out Harlan's last episode
if you haven't seen Harlan's last
episode on here it's unlike any episode
we've had in the entire run of the
Honeydew oh really yeah no one's had a
dog get abducted by an owl no one well
murdered murdered it was an Almer yeah
yeah no one's had that yeah that's a
unique story too I I gotta say you
yeah I don't want anyone have you ever
met another person whose dog's been
abducted murdered excuse me by an owl no
and I I hope I never do I got one it's
because of you I have two umbrellas over
my balcony because we have at barn owls
that live right over here in these trees
oh yeah I do videos of them all the time
they're two or three of them Circle
they're hunting in a smaller [ __ ]
apartment I have my dog she was three
pounds I'm like you gave me trauma and
then I even tried to get her one of
those spiky vests yeah so the Hawks
don't grabmanship but that was it looks
she looked like a [ __ ] armadillo it
was excessive like a punk rock armadillo
yeah owls and Hawks they look they have
this site they're a unique vision and
when they look down there they move um
they're silent yeah they're silent and
when they look down and see a small dog
they just see like a lamb chop running
you know yeah it's like a pork chop or a
lamb chop and it's like
Chilly Willy um well this time we're not
gonna be talking about animals
um so you had a couple stories you
wanted to share
um and you know this is your episode
yeah yeah please well I have an
interesting app uh story that happened
to me that I thought you might find
pretty weird and cool it's kind of like
a Ghost Story meets Highway to Heaven
type of thing okay you know yeah it's uh
also old enough to Remember
by the way I think Chilly Willy did an
episode of Highway to Heaven too
remember he was possessed yeah
Michael Landon pouring holy water on a
little Chilly Willy penguin yeah yeah oh
catboy yeah this little stitched where's
Waldo cap by the way am I the only guy
that doesn't give a [ __ ] where Waldo is
[ __ ] off I hope Waldo's stuck in a bear
trap in Montana
getting eaten by mountain lions that
[ __ ] googly eyes he's giving
everybody eye issues squinting and
looking for this [ __ ] in a [ __ ]
Waldo it's kind of like it should be
like where's pervo like he's like he's
always there kind of behind the Eiffel
Tower behind the bushes it's like dude
stay out of my yard I feel like he's
watching me undress at night
anyway sorry I digress
but um
this story stems from
um do you remember sort of your first
love that you're like in college did you
have a girl that you were madly in love
with and just drove you nuts yeah senior
year high school oh and it ended
obviously oh yeah yeah and was it brutal
yeah it was pretty brutal yeah I mean I
took it hard it's hard and when you're
young when you when you're in your like
mid-20s you're still figuring out love
and emotions and this stuff's really
wrong still right we're always doing
being messy yeah yeah but when you're
when you're at that age it's like really
like nerve ending like it's really fresh
and new and comes down on you like an
avalanche
so um I had been with my college
sweetheart for like probably five years
and this was just when I was starting to
do comedy of all things I ended up
getting a job with the police this was
up in Toronto okay so I got a job
working for the police in the mail room
of all things so you're not are you an
actual officer no no I'm not a cop I'm
just in the mail room and then twice a
day I have a special car and I have to
drive from where I work where all the
mail comes in and go down to Police
Headquarters I have to circulate in the
morgue and the forensics while you're
walking around and delivering everywhere
I have full access to the the police
force and and and so this is at a point
in my life where I was doing this as a
day job working as a you know a male guy
and then the police station the police
force and then at night I was starting
to do my stand-up comedy so I was just
getting going my life was starting to
roll
and in all of this I've got this kind of
relationship that's falling apart
with kind of the love of my life my
college sweetheart
and when I did my route every day I had
to like kind of twice a day I had to go
down by the shores of Lake Ontario go to
Police Headquarters then drive back
Uptown to where my office was and did
this every day five days a week
but I'm going through this thing like do
I stay with this girl do I leave this
girl we're in there why what was
happening at that point where you're
there was a point where we were madly in
love but then she she cheated on me and
I caught her hmm how did you catch her
like in the ACT no it was it was very
bizarre we had moved in together
and you know sometimes your instincts
just know if that someone's cheated on
you your gut it's just and it's so
strong and you feel horrible about it
because you don't want to be that I
don't trust you person you know but when
something doesn't leave you you you go
why is this why and so we lived on the
back end of a golf course up in Toronto
and it was a winter night and we're
living together and I'm thinking do we
get married do we move forward do we do
we go to the next level but I still had
this nagging thing and I'd asked her
many times I said look just tell me did
you cheat on me I I can feel it you know
we can work it out maybe I don't know at
least we can have a dialogue we can
discuss it
and and it just wasn't coming you know
she was telling me nothing happened and
so one night I went down into the
golf course in the middle of the night
snowing it's like this deep it's you
walked down I walked down
and I just looked to the sky I go God
please give me an answer did she cheat
on me give me an answer please like I
need to know like I've like I had these
big plans for my life I knew I wanted to
go to Hollywood I knew I wanted to take
a shot at doing something in the
entertainment like I had big plans I I
knew I wasn't gonna have a mediocre life
and I thought if I'm gonna bring this
person with me
I want it to be the right person and so
I was like please give me an answer I
remember getting on my knees and
sticking my face in the snow like just
numbing my face
I could never tell this is foreign
I just shoved my face just Frozen throw
it like out of the house in the middle
of the [ __ ] night Trek down to like
an opening yeah in the I'm in the golf
course I'm on like it's this huge
beautiful pine trees everywhere in the
middle of Toronto but now you know Golf
Course is a giant Park so there was no
one around big thick snowflakes it's
like a scene right out of yeah it's a
wonderful life you know you know please
go on help me you know
you know is where he's about to jump off
the bridge but I didn't have a bridge so
I just stuck my face in the snow
and um I went home and the next day
I was looking around the house I was
cleaning or whatever we had a little one
bedroom apartment
and I look in our closet and I see this
this bag like kind of a bag and I
remembered oh that's her bag uh and I
hadn't seen it there before and I pulled
it out
and there was a notepad in it
and I opened the notepad and in the
notepad were two handwritten letters
one was to me
saying all this stuff about you know
blah blah blah blah blah blah and then
the second one was to the this guy
so
she was caught she was busted and so I
ended it but I still was so in love with
her and we tried to work through it and
just couldn't get there and I was
struggling I was like how do I get it
going with someone I don't trust right
right
and so cut to now I'm working for the
police
I'm doing my route and I'm still
struggling with this thing and every day
I went back to the same place from
Police Headquarters back to the same
place and so this damn really like going
nuts like God I need an answer so for
the first time
since I'd worked there I drove past my
building I I drove North where you live
uh well no where I work so I drove past
work and I just kept going right up the
road
and as I was driving I did it again I
went I went God please give me the
answer like what am I supposed to do
with this girl there's all this stuff
and and so I'm driving along and I go
about like two miles north of work which
I never do
and I see this burger joint called the
fire pit you know I pull in and it's
this sign it's like Flames coming up and
it's called the fire pit and I'd been
there before it's like delicious burgers
right and so I go into the place and
it's one of those places where you stand
at the counter like McDonald you look up
at the menu and then you order what you
want then you sit down so I go and I
look around there's no one there this is
like four o'clock in the afternoon I'm
supposed to finish work at five right
so I go I'm just gonna get a burger I'm
gonna sit down and you know I just said
this crazy prayer give me an answer
and
I order my burger I get it I sit down in
a little booth you know a little bench
on each side I got my burger and as I'm
looking down I'm starting to open it all
of a sudden I feel someone slide in
right across from me
and before I tell you any more I'm a
horror movie Freak Like I love horror
movies like you know Freddy the 13th
Jeepers Creepers
yeah
all those guys you know Halloween
Halloween Michael Myers that first
Halloween's a fantastic it's great and I
love getting scared and I love the
thrill of it so not much phases me so
I'm sitting down at the fire pit I'm
just about to unwrap my burger and I
feel someone slide in right across from
me but there'd been no one in this place
it's not a big place
and I literally look up
and sitting directly across from me
is a woman probably about 45 years old
and she's got long
hair gray hair
like it almost looked like a lady
outside today yeah just like but but
this really weird gray and it looked it
looked like scraggly dead hair okay and
then I looked right in her eyes and her
eyes were gray I've never seen someone
with gray eyes like a gray sky during a
stormy day they were foggy and Misty and
I'm telling you Ryan my I was just
sitting there normal and I don't know if
you've ever been scared I'm scared right
my fear I could feel it go up like a
thermometer just one and in my head I
went oh my God this person is dead you
really thought that that's right the
only thing that went into my head I went
and I just felt like Terror like I
looked at her hair her skin her eyes had
never seen and she's just staring right
at me I go this person is dead like Dead
face not a smile not any expression
nothing no it just felt like it was a
living dead purse percent and I go this
person is dead and she opens her mouth
and I'm not making it she goes I died
nine months ago no Harley get the [ __ ]
I still get goosebumps it my fear I I
just telling me you sat down unwrap a
burger and this lady slides in out of
nowhere he looks at you and the first
thing she says is I died I died nine
months ago she'd looked I thought she
was dead the minute I looked at her and
my thing went like this and I was so
scared I couldn't I froze I wanted to
scream I've never wanted to scream I
literally wanted to go like just scream
and I couldn't I was literally like just
like
staring at her
and I couldn't I froze I was I was
terrified dude and she goes
I'm a diabetic this was after about 30
45 seconds of Silence no that's how it
started it was that long before she said
she just sat there and I'm just like
whole like I couldn't even talk I've
never been like that she goes I'm a
diabetic
I had whatever happens when you have go
into diabetic shocks like she said I was
dead for eight or nine minutes and they
brought me back
no this is a zombie this so I'm just
freaking terrified and I didn't know
what to do I couldn't move I was just
somehow locked into this person it's
like I'm just [ __ ] with you got my
burger
you know it's like I'm like sitting
there at the fire pit and it's like I
wanted to have a cheeseburger yeah
there's a dead lady I wasn't looking to
have brunch with Beelzebub you know what
I mean
I want I want onion rings not uh lunch
with Satan thank you very much
this is wild it was insane I was
terrified I'm like give me some curly
fries there Lucifer you know it's just
like
so I'm sitting there completely
terrified
and she starts talking about her
experience when she was on the other
side she goes they brought me back with
I don't know if they give him some kind
of shot or something like that
and she starts talking about she goes I
met God I met this man with a long
flowing white beard a long
flowing robe and you're just sitting
there you haven't said a word I can't
move I've never been like this somebody
I haven't said a word and she just
starts talking and so I'm like terrified
and then she starts talking about
this was God and I touched his face and
I was there with them and now I start
sort of going from terrified that the
Red Zone goes down and she starts
talking about the afterlife and all this
and that and now I'm sort of going the
other way where I'm starting to get like
elated like I'm like oh my God maybe he
she's about to tell you the answer to
the prayer you've been asking yeah and
I'm just like messenger I don't know
what she is I'm thinking is this an
angel and I go from a completely
terrified to completely like Enchanted
by this person and then and then the
last thing she's not the last the second
last thing she says to me she goes God
told me that where we are on Earth this
is hell
and that kind of freaked me out a bit
she goes but there's a better place
and it's kind of like I said go well why
is she telling me all this this wasn't
my prayer
and then we go from from that moment she
finally stops and now I'm elated I don't
want her to stop talking I went from
complete Terror to keep talking it was
just like I was like there was some kind
of like being between us and then she
just abruptly stopped she stood up stood
at the edge of the booth and just looked
at me and goes find the right girl no
Is that real dude that's a hundred
percent real
find the right girl and I'm just sitting
there like this she just walks away goes
out the side exit
and I'm like this isn't real that that's
an Angel that's I don't know what that
is and so I sat there for about probably
45 seconds and I go I've got to go see
if that's a real thing or because no one
else seemed to notice there was no one
else in there I ran to the side door
never never a physical touch or anything
never touched I ran I looked out the
side door and I did see her walking down
the street so I went okay I almost
thought I wouldn't but that told me it
was real
and that was it that was it it was it
was the strangest that's scary scariest
weirdest experience yeah and so as so
many things I want to ask you but
this do you think like because she had
been dead for so long this is what her
eyes look like now I couldn't understand
it is that a lack of like I mean we are
not doctors in any way here but is that
a lack of oxy like what the [ __ ] I don't
mind was she blind she wasn't blind I've
never seen eyes that color in my life
I've never seen them since I've never
seen eyes that were so kind of dead when
they when they stared but they were a
smoky gray unlike I've ever seen ever
and it it just blew my mind
when when I my first thought was this
person is dead and then she goes I died
nine months ago I just about
you know
dude how was the burger
flame broiled let me tell you that much
my man it was I don't even remember the
goddamn Burger when I when they did when
a demon sits down or an angel she might
have took it with her yeah I should have
noticed the damn thing was gone the
whole thing was a con job by Satan to
get my damn meat oh man you bear your
face in snow in the middle of the night
in a golf course and then you're driving
and again and then you sit down and a
[ __ ] lady slides in the booth and has
dead eyes and says I died nine months
ago yeah they brought me back I met God
I touched his beard and she gets up and
says find the right girl that's the only
thing she said and she just walked away
just one and I'm good how [ __ ] insane
it's insane on two levels because you
know people sometimes scoff at the power
of prayer or they they mock it or they
don't believe it and you have every
right to believe it or not believe it
that that's fine
but I found it astounding that the night
I asked for an answer to the cheating
the next day I found this notepad in a
bag that'd been sitting there for a
whole year I just happened to check it
and then you know months later as I'm
driving I go to this location I never go
to and I'm trying to figure out how am I
going to make it work with this person I
know she cheated can I do this I'm
conflicted confused I've got all these
things going on inside me here and I
assigned my prayer was what do I do what
should I do and then this person this
entity and I've never experienced any
just stands up and the only thing she
says to me is go find the right girl
out of all the things she could have
said yeah
so it it's it was just
wild it was like like a crazy I went
from completely horrified to completely
Enchanted to completely mystified okay
so now what happens you go home and do
you immediately split and are you in
better spirits about this breakup like
what happens I'm both and you tell her
you know I don't I never told her the
story because it was I don't think she
would believe it and and I sort of just
ended it after that because you know I I
was already conflicted because of the
cheating and then
I thought like this was such a direct
answer
and I just I just sort of severed the
ties and we drifted apart and then you
know with a lot of relationships Time
Heals things and to this day we still
talk we're still friends
but
it never worked out that we became you
know husband and wife or lifelong
Partners but
um you know people go through rough
stuff and breakups and but this was just
a really
weird way to get answers and insight and
you know I'm not pushing religion on
anyone but sometimes you know prayer is
a very powerful force
it also may it is and also makes me
wonder and even if you don't believe in
prayer the power of thinking minus the
religion or whatever behind it is still
the same work you're doing you know
still focusing on that thing and and
envisioning it and
um but also I wonder like
if that lady doesn't slide in that Booth
how much longer you
do you stay with this woman or how much
longer do you are you in turmoil about
this you know and and also to a lot of
our uh uh
in our defense I think we do get signs
that sometimes we don't see yeah we miss
whatever and I wonder if you hadn't
gotten any and then they finally were
like just send that lady over there to
[ __ ] yourself you know yeah I mean we
don't get this it was so extreme yeah
so Blacky with Satan I mean it doesn't
get any more direct man it's just like
you know it just it was just brutal so
yeah yeah and and I don't really
subscribe to the whole religious God
prayer thing I believe in a bigger
entity like a powerful force in the
world that I conceive as God and and uh
I it's not that I disavow religion but
it's I don't follow it I'm not immersed
in organized religion but I do believe
in a higher God is what we all decide to
ah perceive God and so
so it's it's really uh it was really
interesting yeah
yeah
have you ever had any other I mean
that's extreme have you ever had any
other moments like that in your life
where something's just
sent your way
not to that I mean I don't know that
anyone's gonna have one like that it was
so special it's a lifetime thing yeah
and to have one of them happen overnight
and the other one happened
within an hour
it was yeah I don't know that I've had
any other experiences that were quite so
abrupt and shocking and and on the money
you know really crazy
if you've got family and friends coming
for the holidays then you're already
anticipating that oh my gosh do I have
enough food feeling it's not fun but
there's no need for it get wild grain
and you will always have crowd-pleasing
bread rolls pastries pastas and more
right in your freezer Walgreens is the
first baked from Frozen box for
artisanal bread while grain uses only
clean ingredients and tastes better than
anything you can find in a grocery store
every item bakes from Frozen in 25
minutes or less and plus for every new
member while grain donates six meals to
the Greater Boston food bank this
holiday season Walgreens featuring
delicious new limited time sweet treats
such as pumpkin cinnamon rolls orange
cranberry biscuits and chocolate
Avalanche croissants all you have to do
is sign up at walgreens.com honeydew and
choose which type of box you want to
receive and how often it's easy to
reschedule skip or cancel I've said it
before I'll say it again this isn't your
typical Frozen Breads and pastas ever
everything comes out fresh and tastes
amazing without all the hard work hungry
already for a limited time you can get
thirty dollars off the first box plus
free croissants in every box when you go
to walgreens.com honeydew to start your
subscription you heard me free
croissants in every box and thirty
dollars off your first box when you go
to walgreens.com honeydew that's
wildgrain.com honeydew or you can use
promo code honeydew at checkout now
let's get back to the do
but it just it it plays into what a what
a crazy wild world we live in
and sort of to segue on the back of that
story
you know it's it's interesting because
at that point in my life I was breaking
into comedy and the world was still sort
of fresh and new to me and and you know
the world's still sort of a Rosy place
when you're coming up in your mid-20s
and you haven't had any real trauma in
your life I came up in a very normal
happy family you know no divorce no
violence no
substance abuse so life was pretty
normal for a guy like me and then here I
am working for the police
and now I'm networking throughout all
these Departments of the police
and here's Mr Right out of college you
know Chuckles McGinty going into comedy
yeah and now I'm exposed to this stuff
like I can I have imagery in my head
from working for the police where
I realized quickly that you know how
there's this thing they call the dark
web how many people do you know have
been on the dark web I've never been on
I have never been on right but you hear
about it and apparently you click and
whatever there's another internet where
it's dark where you can get drugs and
sex and violence and who knows what's on
get that on a regular internet yeah but
so so imagine what the dark web is like
right it that's the underbelly that's
kind of where probably you know the
demons live that's where this lady went
back to the ones the thing I can't
decide if she was a demon or an angel
yeah you know what because I don't get
to know what they look like it's all
about their energy it was about the
energy you gotta say that's an angel
then yeah the fact that it was so scary
at first but by the end I I didn't want
her to leave
but also if you really are alive and you
were dead you don't look that bad you
know you look pretty good oh my goddamn
Burger back yeah
you don't need to eat you're dead
[ __ ] [ __ ] Angel
God by the way do you still have
diabetes yeah did that go did that die
with your whole body yes I really want
to know actually do they have the
needles up in heaven yeah
but if you had diabetes and you died and
you came back as diabetes yeah are you
clear did you beat diabetes I think you
probably do like if you die you kind of
get cured you should be able to come
back and reset everything brand new yeah
oh yeah you're good go get a burger
go have a cheeseburger you're cleansed
colon cancer no Go Get It Go Get a
double cheeseburger you've earned it
dead eyes
old gray stoke
oh Lord
[Laughter]
so yeah so here I am rolling around yeah
sorry working for the police
McGinty like just starting into the
comedy world
life's you know life's my oyster
and now I'm like walking into the
forensic lab
you know the guys the the forensic
guys are showing me you know they're
holding up skulls with circles in them
I'm like why is there a circle that big
in that skull and go this is where
someone put a hammer through someone's
head I'm like okay thanks for showing me
that this is just their day-to-day [ __ ]
this is stuff in there off you're just
bringing mail by I'm just dropping by
and suddenly I get [ __ ] Dr holyhead
you know thanks a lot
here's your envelope thanks for the
midnight Horror Story you know
you know
and then I walk in there another day and
I walk in and I go right into the lab
where they do all the forensics right
I'm in the morgue and on the floor close
a shirt socks
Underpants jeans
blood splattered on a bunch of the
clothing and on the table on the autopsy
table a white sheet
and out from under the sheet a rope
with a split in it and blood on the Rope
and I can see the shape of the body
underneath and I said to the forensic
doctor I said what's what happened here
and he goes this is a woman who was
suicidal
jumped off a 35-story balcony at her
apartment tied the Rope around her neck
when the Rope went taut it snapped and
she fell all the way down no and I'm
just sitting here going this is a human
life here and I'm looking at these
clothes like you know it sounds stupid
but it's just they're jeans just like I
would wear or just a shirt you'd see on
your sister just a little bit ago that
was a person yeah and now they're
they're a mound under a sheet and then
just this rope coming out from under the
sheet and twirling on the floor and I
felt like I was in a Stephen King novel
you know you still like horror moves
after all this [ __ ] I do but it it it it
it put a whole new spin on it you know
because when you see this real stuff
and then I remember going one day down
to Police Headquarters and Toronto
Canada was kind of more of a happy
non-violent type of place we don't have
guns I mean there's bad things that
happen here and there are murders but up
until this point
we'd never really had like a child
abduction murder kind of rape thing I
hate to even say those terms together
but during my time at the cops
ah this little girl was abducted from
like a soccer tournament at a local
arena
and she was abducted raped murdered and
here I am again driving in down to
Police Headquarters to drop off the mail
and this thing's been in the newspapers
from the page like yeah it was kind of
when Toronto in my mind and Canada kind
of took that turn where we're kind of
this happy great place and then all of a
sudden
that horrible thing happened and nothing
was ever going to be the same but here
I'm driving and pulling up and there
they are pulling the girls body out of
the back of the ambulance again with a
tarp over it and I'm watching this
little girl go by after reading about it
all this time
and then you know I'd get mail that
would come through in the mail room and
I would see stuff you know I'd have to
open the mail and then distribute it
and every now and then I'd get graphic
police photographs from crime scenes oh
my God you're seeing this [ __ ] I see
this stuff and and you know I'm still
young and impressionable and there's a
few images that I'll never forget there
was an image of a probably about a 10
year old girl
a beautiful lake with a Sandy Beach
almost a sunset
and laying in the water in about
probably I don't know a foot and a half
of of water rate where the water's
coming up on the beach
a little girl
like doggy style like like you know
laying down face forward or butt
sticking in the air her arms bound
and a cinder block on her head no yeah
like just
crazy [ __ ] and then I'll tell you one
more example but the reason I'm saying
all this and you see that mental image
in your head well let me put it this way
I've been all over the world I've been
to art galleries where I've seen the
Mona Lisa and Van Gogh's starry night
and those I sort of remember
these images are crystal clear yeah
these are crystal clear images
and it's stuff you don't get rid of and
the last image I'll never forget is it
was a you know I'm opening the mail I
pull out photographs and it's a guy by
the way they should absolutely on the
[ __ ] interview give you a heads up
there might be some [ __ ] that you don't
want to see on this job that anyone ever
tell you that you'd be going to the
morgue and seeing dead bodies or skulls
with uh hammer holes in them and these
graphic images or anything like that no
because I surprise to you I sort of got
the job on a fluke I was hired to come
in for a month to clean up in the
warehouse you know the government has so
many documents you know so they had a
warehouse basement room like documents
to the roof of government form for this
form for that form for this and
basically they needed someone to clean
it up because it was a nightmare so I
went in for a took me a month to to
stack and organize and throw out like it
was it was endless and I did it and in
the time that I was doing it the guy who
worked in the mail room had a heart
attack
and the guys are so in a Wonder right
yeah
oh no wonder they said a heart attack
but I think he got a hammer to the Head
yeah
there it is right there I'm about to
have one right here listen to this chick
God damn and so they were so impressed
with how I organized this chaotic like
Mass they couldn't believe I I did it so
well they offered me the job in the mail
room and to be The Driver to deliver the
mail all around so I I had no real idea
of what I was getting if I said yeah it
was great because I was doing comedy at
night I was just getting into it and
here I had this secure government job
with you know dental and medical and I
almost didn't leave it it was so they
make it so cushy and you're also not
stuck in an office all day you're out
driving around the city you have a route
things like that it's it's half an hour
half the days in the office doing the
mail and the other half's driving around
and delivering so one of the other
images that I pulled out I'm sorry if
this is too bad this is what the show is
man you have to live with it it blows me
away that yeah I hear you starry night
is like I remember that but this [ __ ]
remember vividly oh yeah I mean Mona
Lisa and a kid with a brick on her head
I mean the police told me the father put
it on her head like the dad yeah the dad
and you're just like so now I'm exposed
to all this stuff and one of the last
images I'll mentioned it's pretty
graphic but it leads into the a bigger
kind of mentality that I have towards
police which I think a lot of people
need to hear and don't hear about but
the last picture was of a guy a white
guy just sitting in a chair on his couch
arms you know on the on the chair one on
one of them on his lap
and jeans shirt
head face mustache and then mustache
perfect as perfect as mine and yours and
from the top of the mustache Gone Gone
just a clean almost like a saw took it
off but the must everything perfect and
on the wall behind
oh in between his legs a shotgun
and I'm just like holy go like the the
casualness of it the fact that it just
looked like a guy sitting there but then
you realize
from here up is just cleanly gone God
and I went holy [ __ ] I go I'm a kid and
look at this stuff and then I've carried
it with me my whole life and then I look
at today and I'm not saying there aren't
bad cops out there I'm not there's
always great cops there's always cops
that there's good and bad everything
right but what people don't know
is the cops
live and function in that dark web that
none of us most of us have never seen we
watch TV shows oh look at you know CSI
the murder it's all it's all phony it's
all it's all entertainment believe it or
not can you believe that the majority of
the top shows that we watch are about
other human beings being murdered what's
that say about us
but these police when you get pulled
over for a ticket when you get stopped
in the street
these most of these cops are just trying
to do their job and what people don't
realize is that police yesterday that
policeman or policeman was scrubbing
that head off that wall or dealing with
a 10 year old little girl the cinder
block on her head like yeah or picking
up somebody parents yeah you know and so
it really gave me such an insight to
what the police psychologically have to
go for people in law enforcement
they live and breathe in that dark world
and for myself when I saw this stuff I
had an epiphany where I went
I didn't think human beings could do
this stuff to each other I knew people
thought and I knew that people you know
disagree and there's murders and but
when you see it raw and you you see it
in real life it's so powerful and it's
so dark
and it was one of the other driving
forces for my comedy because I went you
know it was interesting that it happened
at that time when I was starting kind
because I went this is such a dark force
this is such a dark horrible area
and I'm pursuing a life where maybe I
can put joy and life on top of it and
and it to me I realize wow there's a
balance here but I don't know if I was
meant to see that stuff to sort of help
me or
but it it really is powerful
how often do those images rotate through
your head
it's not like I'm traumatized by them
and I I lay awake at night and think
about but they're always there like I'll
never forget that someone ever you want
yeah and and they'll pop up I mean they
can as as horrible as it sounds
sometimes if I see a picturesque lake or
an ocean set with a beach
sometimes I don't pop into my head and
it doesn't
I've never let that Darkness
slow me down if anything I've I've used
it as fuel to go
what what can we do to creep light into
the world how do we how do we break open
the darkness and let light in and
hopefully through comedy and laughter
and you know I would say laughter is joy
and so
but but people next time they're pulled
over by the cops and they decide hey
[ __ ] you pig and you know uh you know
defund the police people don't really
know what these guys see every day and
what they have to do and the guts they
have to clean up and the babies they
have to carry down the stairs that have
been murdered and so it's pretty pretty
intense
do you have any family in law
enforcement
uh well believe it or not my my dad was
a politician so he was actually just as
fate would have it I worked in the
solicitor general building in Toronto
and prior to that my dad was the
solicitor general what is a solicitor
that's the equivalent of the Attorney
General in the states so my dad was a
pretty Toronto yeah he was in Ontario on
the province so he was a minister which
is a pretty powerful spot and of course
they didn't know that about me when I
went in there the kid in the basement
so all these people are working for the
ministry of the solicitor general and
they didn't know he's currently in
office while you're doing that no he he
was the he was uh probably there a year
before oh wow so it's fresh out right
yeah so nobody knew that I was the you
know I was the former um Minister's kid
because and I wasn't gonna advertise and
then one day my boss like calls me and
goes was your father our our former
solicitor general and I go yeah and he
was just like it was just so weird it
was so weird like they could because I
had long hair down to here you did I was
just supposed to work down in the
warehouse you know so I was just kind of
a I had long hair and I was like a young
guy just out of college so it was pretty
pretty weird the way that all came
together
man I am talking about that that gunshot
I had a friend of mine when I first
lived here this was in the 90s
he uh his name is Dave Knight is a great
dude
took me in when I first moved here laid
on his couch for a while but he was gun
crazy he had a couple nine millimeters
or whatever but he was also the super of
the building and you know we had a gang
banger upstairs and he was from New York
and he wasn't [ __ ] around and like he
would come out in the middle of the
night he'd throw a [ __ ] gun at me
like come on I'm like I'm there like
come on [ __ ] I'm sitting I'm watching
Saturday Night Live dude yeah
I'll never forget it was one night we
heard this pop and it sounded like a
gunshot out there and he came running
out through a [ __ ] nine I was like
I'm watching Saturday Night Live I
remember the Saturday Night Live I was
it was Martin Lawrence the one where on
the East Coast he said some offensive
[ __ ] about washing your ass and using a
stick up or something and they delayed
it and after that it was always a tape
delay on that for for a while it was
yeah but um
he would play Russian Roulette too he
had a revolver and he would [ __ ] put
a put one in the chamber and he'd spin
it he'd look he'd clearly look and then
I I was like dude and it would freak me
the [ __ ] out he would play Russian
Roulette in front of you yeah he would
just put it in but he would spin it and
clearly look and then click and I'd be
like no dude no
yeah so I had gone home for the summer I
come back uh this is 94. I'm going to
college at Cal State Northridge and um
I'm supposed to meet him for lunch
and he goes hey can we do a little later
I go yeah no problem he's like like one
or two I go yup please tell me you went
to the fire pit so I go to the fire pit
for a Char-Broil Burger
and this deadly though so I wish it was
as good as uh ending of your story so um
that day you know
look when when weird [ __ ] happens
schedules like you said they get thrown
off you drove North that time or
whatever it was all it was something
always different yeah it was weird yeah
normally yeah I get there early I knew
we weren't having lunch anyway but I get
there early anyway and I call anyway why
I knew we weren't he wasn't going to be
ready
and this voice answers and I say hey
this is uh it's Dave there he's like no
he's not gonna take a message and I said
yes this is Ryan I'm supposed to meet
him for lunch
um and he's like well
um I have to tell you that I'm the
homicide detective and uh your friend is
um he's passed away and I was like and I
knew I knew it was a gun right away I
knew something with the gun right away
whoa so then
uh it doesn't hit me like I'm like what
and I go over anyway
and the gang banger that we talked to
all the time was up on his balcony and
again I know he's not there yeah and I
said hey is Dave here and he goes nah
and I could tell he's like he's gone and
when he said he's gone I was like this
shit's real so I go up they won't let me
in the apartment
and our friend tells me that he had two
friends visiting from New York so
imagine having two people come to your
home they're hanging out we're all
buddies we've known each other for years
and he does the stupid Russian Roulette
thing and he spins it he looks and he
misses it and boom he he accidentally
blows his brains out in front of his
friends who are immediately traumatized
oh yeah another friend of his who I had
talked to for a little while comes and
and the other sad thing was Dave's mom
and brother lived in the building
so now they're trying to keep them away
from his place and his friend Matt went
in
I never thought about it but like you
said like it was he told me teeth
hair bones flesh like oh and he's
scrubbing it off this wall that someone
else is going to move into probably in a
month
and yeah that always [ __ ] with me
thinking about just that
[ __ ]
he was just he was just [ __ ] around
what a dumb way to [ __ ] around yeah like
you know if you're feeling around and
you know you're never gonna shoot
yourself then what's the point of
[ __ ] around right and you know one
day you're gonna get it wrong because
that's the way odds work if you throw 10
pennies in the air that's right it's
rare you're gonna get ten heads or ten
Tails but every now and then if you do
it enough you're gonna get all ten yeah
yeah that's brutal wow and then I think
about that too I think about those yeah
and I think about those cops too like
you say who were that was their
afternoon is you know and and at what
point do you get so numb where you're
like now we're just another guy shot
himself another [ __ ] dad murdered his
kid another like yeah you're right about
that like it's I think you get numb and
a Darkness creeps into you and you you
sort of have to let it live there but
that's what I'm saying when when you
encounter police and they're yeah they
don't want to give you a park or a
speeding ticket but that's part of their
job you know or they don't necessarily
want to hassle you or ask you what
you're doing there but that's that's the
job they've been assigned and when you
see people being belligerent and angry
and rude and and pushing back again if
it's a bad cop okay but it seems more
and more these days people are just
pushing back for the thrill of it to see
if they can annoy the cop everyone's
holding up their cell phones like that's
Captain America's shield hey what are
you gonna you know what I mean like well
people walk up a [ __ ] grizzly bear in
the woods
[Music]
good bear good bear like they actually
say good bear stay there a bit like
they're calling it bear like it knows
what it is
and they think their [ __ ] phone's
gonna protect them
and it's like man they don't know
right so I can also like it speaks
English yeah yeah there's bear in all
kinds of languages every language has
the word Fair how do you know he doesn't
speak German yeah you think the bear is
going oh is that an iPhone
is that the new 14. oh my okay I'm not
gonna Maul you today but if you had an
Android I would have eaten you for lunch
man that is so true but yeah so it's
just it's like think about the Journey
of of the next law enforcement person
you encounter think about where they
were hours ago or yesterday or even a
year ago or the call before this one
right and they're they're carrying the
burden of the dark underbelly of society
for us
they have to deal with it and even they
go you asked me if I was prepared if
they had you know set me up to know
about any of the the cops are they are
told what they're gonna run into and
it's got to be traumatizing and horrible
and and
so spread light where you can spread Joy
where you can and remember the Journey
of the law enforcement person that's you
know would more than likely take a
bullet for you if if there was a
shootout you know
so
um let's go back to your dad for a
second here that's a powerful position
what's it like growing up as a kid with
your dad what is it called again the
what general well he was the solicitor
general he started off as a local
politician like an older men and then
became an MPP a member of provincial
Parliament and then uh ended up in the
top position of the attorney general for
how long or the solicitor general which
is basically he oversees all of law
enforcement for the province so it's a
when you asked if my dad was in law
enforcement in essence he was the top
the top dog for the time he was he was
the minister you ever talked to him
about the crazy [ __ ] he's seen or dealt
with I never have no because he's
probably I mean think of the little
microscope you got yeah and what he's
dealing with with all of law enforcement
yeah it's interesting you asked me that
question because I never even considered
it till now that's that's weird because
I I guess I I don't really have that
kind of open dialogue with my dad like
that but you never told him what you saw
no nothing none of this no no no
wow yeah yeah and it didn't occur to me
that you know my dad's probably seen way
more than me you know it's funny you
just said that right now because it
didn't really enter my mind but it's
probably because it's like oh it's your
father your father you know they're
grown-ups they're you know they're fine
yeah yeah so you know think about that
like if you're talking about all cops
live in that dark underbelly yeah think
of what your dad lives yeah your dad
lived in all of like just take SWAT
alone there yeah the [ __ ] beat cops
that the [ __ ] murders the this the
the missing kids the all that he's
overseeing all of that well I don't know
how immersed he got in like daily
day-to-day crime cases my dad at that
level oversees legislation and is
working on actually passing and creating
laws so it's probably more of a
legislative level that my dad functioned
at that he's coming up through the ranks
all the way to that level though yeah
well in that situation he was a member
of Parliament and was assigned this so
it's not my dad did not you know rise up
through law enforcement but that being
said he had to have been privy and
probably seen a lot of things that
interestingly enough I've never asked
him about I'm sure if I saw what I saw
in a year
um and I saw a lot yeah dude and that's
all in one year yeah he he probably saw
a lot too so yeah interesting oh maybe
I'll ask him one day
yeah see what he says do you ever Miss
do you ever think if you didn't do
comedy do you think you'd still be doing
that job or working somewhere in that
field you said you'd like they made it
so cush for you it was it was scary
right there were moments where I was up
on the 12th floor and I was still trying
to figure out this girlfriend
and here I was just starting comedy the
most unpredictable career path you could
ever imagine and when I started comedy
in the early 80s
it wasn't comedy wasn't like you know
nowadays every third person you meet's
doing stand up and there's 7 000 clubs
across North America when I started
there was one club in the whole country
one comedy club and 12 Headliners where
this was in Toronto well Club it was
called yuck yucks okay yeah yeah and I
thought man if I could break into that
if I could break into that was it really
dude it was empty and then I didn't even
know about what was going on in the
States because when you're up there back
then it was too hard to
um so basically I gave myself five years
I said I'll try for five years and if I
don't get paid in five years I'll get
out so here I am stepping into the most
unpredictable
unsecure career path you could ever want
to take the window was this big to get
through it's like a sperm that one sperm
getting to the egg
and so there were literally days where
I'm standing on the 12th floor looking
out the window down on the city and just
going
I got health insurance I got Dental
I get a three weeks paid vacation I make
pretty good money for a guy working in a
mail room I don't have to think too much
I just deliver mail I drive around I get
an automatic raise every year I get a
bump because that's the government way
it's almost impossible to get fired you
know and I'm like why don't I just marry
this girl and just have this life if
they make it so easy
and that's when my brain went no this is
a trap like of course they make it so
easy so easy to do what nothing to
deliver mail to drive back and forth
every day and see the underbelly of the
world and and and in that moment it
wasn't even an epiphany it was just like
no it was just like I went should I no
just immediately and I said I'll take
the hard road I'll take the risk amen I
don't know what's coming I might I might
be homeless
I remember I used to some days I would
go downtown
and sit with the homeless for half a day
did you really yeah I'd go to I'd find a
homeless guy I'd follow him into
McDonald's and I'd sit at the seat right
beside him just I wanted to it sounds
horrible I wanted to smell it I wanted
to hear it I wanted to see it because I
thought I'm laughing because I wonder if
they go back to their Circle telling
them about the time to [ __ ] blue eyed
guy showed up and [ __ ] sat next time
with the McDonald's yeah it was weird
get that job yeah
I I explored it man but I was like you
know what you just would study like or
would you I would just sit with them no
I would just I would be in their
presence to see what it felt like I
wanted to absorb the experience of being
homelessness of homeless even though I
wasn't I thought what's it like what's
it like to have no responsibility what's
it like to have no commitment to anybody
or anything I thought is this is this
the ultimate freedom in this world we
live in with cities and towns and people
and I sort of already knew it wasn't but
I I wanted to see
and and then then when I got this job I
thought this is an easy Road they've put
in front of me and and I don't know what
it was it's probably the same thing
that's in you it's a bit of a warrior
mentality it's like I want to go to
battle for sure yeah I want to punch my
way through the ranks I wanna not in an
egotistical way but I want to show my
medal I want to show that I can climb
this comedy mountain or go through
contribute or go through let me over it
I'll go through it yeah like I I want I
want this battle I want to be slashing
Through the Jungle all the way to the
top of the mountain you know and and it
was scary it was petrified I had
security I could have had the girl in my
dreams and I just went no I gotta I
gotta take this Challenge and and and go
for it
bro you made the right call Rocket Man
you made the right [ __ ] call
Rocket Man you know there's days when
you you look back on your life and you
go
would life have been different if I just
kind of settled in and and and had the
wife and the kids and kind of did the
the the the regular thing or was this
the right thing I I will never know the
answer to that but all I know is I wake
up invigorated every day and and in
closing I'll say
I feel like
I'm able to put light
over the darkness that exists in the
world by taking the path that I did and
bring laughter and and joy and put a
crack in that Darkness dude you do and
you're great at it brother thank you
great thank you
um thank you this has been an awesome
[ __ ] episode I got chills I got five
[ __ ] emotional
um will you please plug uh whatever
you'd like again yes so um check out my
podcast it's not this deep and dark but
that's why I like coming here because we
get into some lasagna layers bro I like
that one we jump right in the fire pit
here park that priest grease yeah the
priest priest grease all over the place
but my podcast is a lot sort of lighter
and funnier and silly that that that
light I was telling you about and so
check that out the Harland highway it's
on YouTube it's uh launches every
Tuesday morning
and then I also draw my own
um t-shirts yeah uh and if you want a
hand-drawn t-shirt of mine go to
harbling.com scapula guy still there
scapula guy and all I I think I have I'm
coming up on 200 different designs damn
are you really yeah I'll hand draw them
right on the shirt and then when the
original sells we make prints and
they're all available at hard bling so
if someone does get the original
original album someone gets the original
those are expensive they're like 200
bucks because they're original pieces of
art but then from that we sell the the
prints for like 18 19 25 bucks or
something so great yeah so Christmas is
coming up make great gifts and uh buddy
thanks for having me here you got it
brother thank you for coming uh as
always ryansickler.com Ryan sickler on
all your social media talk to y'all next
week
[Music]
foreign
[Music]